Perhaps this question has occurred to you at some point during the last few months. How is it possible that there are people who haven't made up their minds in this election? How is it possible that someone actually hasn't formed an opinion at this point about whether or not they like George Bush? Little children in the most remote villages on Earth, children who don't speak our language or know our ways, have opinions about the president. What more information about him could our fellow American citizens possibly need, you know?
或许过去几个月里，你曾不止一次闪过这个念头：怎么会有人到现在还没决定好选谁呢？怎么会有人到现在还没形成关于自己是否喜欢乔治·布什的看法？哪怕是地球上最偏远村庄里的小孩，那些不懂我们的语言、不了解我们生活方式的孩子，对总统都有自己的看法。我们的美国同胞究竟还能从他身上获取什么额外信息呢？
Well, for months, we've been looking into this question here at our radio show. And yes, there are lots of people who are undecided, because they just don't follow the news, they're too busy at their jobs, they're raising kids, they don't care. Whatever, it's not their thing. I talked to Martha [? Brennan ?] four months after John Kerry wrapped up the Democratic nomination, but before the convention, about what she thought of him.
几个月来，我们在电台节目中一直在探究这个问题。是的，有很多选民尚未决定，是因为他们根本不关注新闻，他们忙于工作、忙于抚养孩子，或者压根不在乎。总之，这不是他们关心的事。约翰·克里获得民主党提名后，但在党代会召开之前，我曾就克里这个人采访过玛莎·布伦南。
I know ?] he was in the Navy. I'm pretty sure he was a senator. And I know he's tall and thin. And that's about all I know.
我知道他在海军服役过。我很确定他曾当过参议员。我还知道他长得又高又瘦。我知道的也就这些了。
But lots of people who are undecided do follow the news, do follow politics. Between 2% and 8% of likely voters are still undecided right now, depending on whose poll you look at. Millions of people, many of them apparently well-informed people who are unhappy with the president but just can't bring themselves to embrace John Kerry. They may decide this election.
但许多尚未决定的选民确实关注新闻，也关注政治。根据不同的民调，目前大约有2%到8%的潜在选民尚未作出决定。这涉及数百万人，其中许多人显然消息灵通，他们对总统不满，但就是无法下定决心支持约翰·克里。他们可能会决定这次选举的结果。
And so, to understand them better, we've been following a few of them for months now as they try to decide. And we have a scoop. We can tell you how it is they decided. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in four acts, two of them about very different undecided voters, one about somebody courting undecided voters, and one about somebody trying to sabotage undecided voters and all other voters. That story from Jack Hitt, and we swear it will get you yelling at your radio.
为了更好地了解他们，过去几个月我们一直追踪采访几位尚未决定的选民，观察他们如何抉择。我们获得了一条独家新闻，可以告诉你他们是如何决定的。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目分为四幕：两幕关于两类截然不同的未决定选民，一幕关于某人如何争取这些选民，还有一幕关于某人如何试图破坏这些选民及所有其他选民的投票。那个故事来自杰克·希特，我们敢保证，听完你会对着收音机大吼大叫。
Act One. James Hackett is one of those undecided voters who does follow politics. He gets his news from NPR and the Wall Street Journal, plus the Atlantic Monthly and Newsweek . He's a doctor in Cincinnati, a diagnostic radiologist, a lifelong Republican. He's never voted for a Democrat for president, and doesn't want to vote for a Democrat for president.
第一幕。詹姆斯·哈克特就是那种关注政治但尚未决定的选民。他从美国国家公共电台、《华尔街日报》，以及《大西洋月刊》和《新闻周刊》获取新闻。他是辛辛那提的一名医生，是一位放射诊断科医生，也是一位终身共和党人。他从未在总统选举中投给民主党，也不想投给民主党。
I have voted Republican every single time, mainly because I think they are more fiscally prudent. That's the main reason. And that's one of the reasons that I am so upset with Bush, one of many reasons.
我每次都投给共和党，主要是因为我觉得他们更懂得精打细算。这是主要原因。这也是我非常不满布什的原因之一，不满的理由有很多。
The Bush tax cut, for instance. If the idea was to stimulate the economy, he says, rich people like him shouldn't have gotten a tax break.
例如布什的减税政策。他说，如果初衷是为了刺激经济，像他这样的富人不应该得到减税。
If he gives me more money off, it's not going to change my spending pattern at all. And I think that the amount of these tax cuts, if they are continued, if they are made permanent, is going to be ruinous, is going to be a phenomenal burden for my children and my grandchildren. And I feel betrayed in a way, and also I feel betrayed because he was promoting himself as a compassionate conservative, which I also really liked the sound of. And of course, that's obviously not what we got. I mean, you want to know everything that I dislike about what Bush has done?
如果他再给我减税，完全不会改变我的消费模式。我认为如果这些减税政策延续下去，如果成为永久性的，那将是灾难性的，会给我子女和孙辈带来巨大的负担。我感到某种程度上的背叛，而且我感到被背叛，是因为他曾以“富有同情心的保守派”自居，我当时真的很喜欢这个说法。当然，我们得到的显然不是那一套。你是想知道我不喜欢布什所作所为的全部理由吗？
It turns out to be a long list. He disagrees with the president about the economy, gay marriage, abortion, health care issues, stem cell research. He's alarmed at how the president has alienated our traditional allies and eroded America's standing in the world. He doesn't fault the president for invading Iraq. Everybody thought there were weapons of mass destruction there, he says.
那将是一长串名单。他在经济、同性恋婚姻、堕胎、医疗保健、干细胞研究等问题上都与总统意见不合。他对总统如何疏远我们的传统盟友并削弱美国在世界上的地位感到震惊。他并不怪罪总统入侵伊拉克。他说，当时每个人都以为那里有大规模杀伤性武器。
So I don't fault him for that, but I do fault him for what has happened afterwards. Before the war started, there were multiple think tanks that were talking about the difficulties of governing in Iraq, and he just completely ignored all of that, how you need more soldiers on the ground if you're going to do it. And I think that has been squandered.
所以我并不因此怪他，但我怪他之后发生的事情。战争开始前，多家智库都在讨论治理伊拉克的难度，而他完全无视了这一切，包括如果你要这么做，就需要更多地面部队。我认为这一切都被挥霍了。
So Dr. Hackett, you sounds like a prime candidate for somebody who'd be voting for John Kerry. What's holding you back from going to Kerry?
哈克特医生，听起来你像是支持约翰·克里的头号人选。是什么让你没能投给克里呢？
Well, there are a number of things. Just as Bush is ultra-conservative, Kerry is ultra-liberal. I mean, I think some people would not call him ultra-liberal, but he's the most liberal man in the Senate. If the Democrats-- I don't know what the heck they were thinking of by nominating such an extreme liberal.
嗯，有很多原因。就像布什是极端保守派一样，克里是极端自由派。有些人可能不会称他为极端自由派，但他确实是参议院里最自由的人。我不知道民主党提名这样一个极端自由派到底在想什么。
I know a lot of guys in my position who voted for Bush, and they don't like him, they don't like the way the country's gone, the way he's going. And if they would have nominated a moderate Democrat, I think this would have been a runaway election. For somebody like me, who has voted Republican all of my life, I shock myself by thinking that I long for the days of Clinton. I can't believe I'm saying this. I would vote for Clinton in a second. I would love to vote for Clinton again.
我认识很多像我一样投给布什的人，他们不喜欢他，不喜欢国家现在的方向，也不喜欢他的行事方式。如果他们提名的哪怕是个温和派民主党人，我想这次选举早就是一边倒了。对于像我这样一辈子都投共和党的人来说，我竟然渴望克林顿执政的日子，这连我自己都感到震惊。我简直不敢相信自己会这么说。我会毫不犹豫地投给克林顿。我很希望能再次投票给克林顿。
You can't believe you're saying this, why? Did you used to hate his guts?
你说这话连你自己都不敢相信，为什么？你以前很恨他吗？
I disliked him. I thought he was-- you know, it depends on what the definition of is is, and you know, all that stuff. But I think what he did was great. I think what he did was very, very good for this country. And I think he actually went against a lot of the Democratic party by moving to the center. But that's how he did some very, very good things.
我曾经很不喜欢他。我想他……你知道，这取决于你怎么定义“是”这个词，诸如此类的事。但我认为他做得很好。我认为他所做的一切对这个国家非常、非常有益。而且我认为他通过转向中间路线，实际上违背了民主党内很多人的意愿。但这就是他取得一些非常、非常好的成就的方式。
Yeah. Listen to yourself.
是啊。听听你自己说的话。
Yeah, I know. I would never in a million years believe I would say that. It's just, I wouldn't believe it.
是啊，我知道。我做梦也没想到我会这么说。我简直不敢相信。
And can I just ask you, when you say that John Kerry is so liberal, I know that that's said all the time, but do you have in mind any specific things that you know that he's voted for that are too liberal for you?
我可以问你一下吗？你说约翰·克里太自由了，我知道这种说法很普遍，但你心里有什么具体的例子，知道他投了哪些对你来说太自由的票吗？
Well, to tell you the truth, I have not gone through his voting record. And I think that's something I should do. I think that's a good point. I think that's something I should do. But I cannot-- you know, actually, that's another problem I had. I went to his website to learn more about him, and actually they didn't talk about his voting record too much on his website. And I'm not sure where to go to get that.
老实说，我还没查过他的投票记录。我觉得这确实是我应该做的事。我觉得你说得对。这确实是我应该做的。但我不能……其实，这是我遇到的另一个问题。我去了他的网站想多了解他，但事实上他们的网站上并没有太多关于他投票记录的信息。我不知道该去哪里找。
Well, listen, I think we're going to want to check back with you and just kind of see how it's going as things heat up.
好吧，听着，随着局势升温，我想我们到时候会再找你，看看情况如何。
That'd be OK. I'll probably be despairing by then.
没问题。到那时我可能已经陷入绝望了。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hello, Dr. Hackett?
喂，是哈克特医生吗？
Yes.
是我。
It's Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Oh, Ira, hi, how're you doing? It's Gig Hackett.
哦，艾拉，你好！你好吗？我是吉格·哈克特。
Gig?
吉格？
G-I-G. It's a nickname I've had forever, and it's just what I go by.
G-I-G。这是我一直用的绰号，大家都这么叫我。
So it's early September, it's the week after the Republican convention. You know, when I last talked to you, you said that the next time that I checked in, you would probably be despairing.
现在是九月初，共和党全国代表大会之后的一周。你知道，上次谈话时，你说下次我再联络你时，你可能已经陷入绝望了。
Yeah, and that is the case. That is the case. You asked me, the last time I talked to you, to give you a call if something happened that may precipitate my movement to one side or the other. And actually, shortly after you said that, I read in Newsweek where Bush had said to this one crowd that he wouldn't do anything different about Iraq. Now, I can't imagine him saying that. I mean, there's so many things after the war that were done poorly, the vast majority of things.
是的，情况确实如此。上次交谈时你让我如果发生什么事可能促使我倒向哪一方的话，就给你打个电话。事实上，在你说了那话不久后，我在《新闻周刊》上读到布什对一群人说，他不会对伊拉克政策做任何改变。天哪，我无法想象他会说出这种话。战争结束后有那么多事情做得糟糕透顶，绝大多数事情都是如此。
You mean the whole post-war planning?
你是说整个战后规划？
Exactly right. Anyway, that was one of the things that I thought, if he's really saying that, there's no way I can vote for him. There's no way. I mean, and as it is, I don't know, I am despairing. I hate both candidates. You know, I just cannot imagine casting a ballot for either one.
完全正确。不管怎样，那是让我觉得如果他真的这么说，我就绝不可能投票给他的原因之一。绝不可能。事实就是这样，我不知道，我陷入了绝望。我两个候选人都讨厌。你知道，我简直无法想象会为他们中的任何一个人投票。
You know, the next big thing that's going to happen is going to be the debates.
你知道，接下来要发生的重大事件就是辩论了。
Oh, absolutely. Oh, debates, that is what I'm waiting for. That's where people get pinned down. That's where people have to take a stand.
哦，当然。哦，辩论，我一直在等这个。那是人们被钉在墙上的时候。那是人们必须表明立场的时候。
Hi, welcome.
嗨，欢迎。
Hi.
嗨。
Come on in.
进来吧。
September 30, the night of the first debate. Gig's house, in the Western Hills suburb of Cincinnati. We've spent enough time on the phone that, yes, now I'm calling him Gig.
9月30日，首场辩论之夜。吉格家在辛辛那提西山的郊区。我们在电话里聊了足够久，所以现在我也叫他吉格。
Well, here, let me introduce you. This is my daughter, Molly.
嗯，来，我为你介绍一下。这是我女儿，莫莉。
Hello.
你好。
Hi, Ira. Good to meet you. Written on your arm is?
嗨，艾拉。很高兴见到你。你胳膊上写的是什么？
Oh, I had a pep rally today at school. It says frosh.
哦，我今天在学校参加了动员大会。上面写着“大一新生”。
In retrospect, this first debate is now seen as one of the big turning points in this election, a decisive win for John Kerry and an embarrassing loss for the president. Poll numbers started rebounding for Kerry afterwards. But what I saw in Gig's basement rec room that night was almost the opposite of what happened in the country as a whole. And it's worth spending a minute talking about it here.
回想起来，这场首场辩论被视为这次选举的重大转折点之一，约翰·克里取得了决定性胜利，总统表现尴尬。辩论后，克里的民调数字开始反弹。但那天晚上我在吉格家的地下室娱乐室里看到的，几乎与全国范围内的反响截然相反。值得花点时间在这里聊聊。
There were seven voters, three for Bush, two for Kerry, two undecided. Cincinnati is Bush country, and most of these seven voted for Bush in 2000. But now, all seven thought the president was doing a lousy job in Iraq and with the economy. Some find the president outright alarming on abortion and social issues. Even his supporters in the group were unhappy with the idea of voting for him again.
当时有七名选民，三名支持布什，两名支持克里，两名未定。辛辛那提是布什的地盘，这七个人中大多数在2000年选了布什。但现在，这七个人都认为总统在伊拉克战争和经济问题上表现糟糕。有些人发现总统在堕胎和社会议题上令人担忧。即使是他在这个群体中的支持者，对再次投票给他也感到不满。
And they all sat down in front of the TV feeling like they still did not know John Kerry. They'd seen the ads, they'd seen the news, but they still didn't get it. What exactly was he going to do for the country?
他们都坐在电视机前，感觉自己还是不了解约翰·克里。他们看过广告，看过新闻，但还是没抓到重点。他到底会为国家做什么？
I do have an indistinct feeling about Kerry. I'd like to know more about his views on the national security issues.
我对克里确实有一种模糊的感觉。我想多了解一下他在国家安全问题上的看法。
Well, ?] first I need to get to know him as a politician.
嗯，我首先需要了解他作为一个政治家的表现。
There's Gig's brother, Ed, and his wife, [? Vicki, ?] friends Paul and Jill, Joy, who works with Gig at the hospital. Gig's wife, [? Joann ?], set up refreshments and red, white, and blue decorations on the ping pong table. And almost from the moment the debate started, this group was deeply skeptical of everything that Kerry had to say. When he accused the Bush administration of letting Osama bin Laden get away at Tora Bora, [? Vicki ?] jumped in.
那是吉格的兄弟埃德，还有他妻子维姬，朋友保罗和吉尔，以及和吉格在医院一起工作的乔伊。吉格的妻子乔安在乒乓球桌上摆好了点心和红白蓝装饰。从辩论开始那一刻起，这个群体就对克里说的一切深表怀疑。当他指责布什政府让奥萨马·本·拉登在托拉博拉逃脱时，维姬插话了。
I don't ?] believe that.
我不信。
When he said that UN inspectors should been given more of a chance in Iraq, Jill spoke up.
当他说应该给联合国检查人员在伊拉克更多机会时，吉尔开口了。
They'd continue inspections forever.
他们会永远检查下去的。
When Kerry explained, correctly by the way, how missteps in the early years of the Bush administration led to North Korea expanding its nuclear program, nobody in the room believed him.
当克里解释（顺便说一句，他解释得很正确）布什政府早期的失误如何导致朝鲜扩大核计划时，房间里没有人相信他。
Did you buy that?
你相信吗？
No, I don't. I mean, I'd like to know more about it.
不，我不信。我想了解更多相关信息。
As Gig put it--
正如吉格所说——
Personally, the things Kerry has said in the past, he's said some things that are inconsistent and some things that are just outright false, in the past. And I mean, I really question. When he says something, I don't know if he really believes that or not.
就我个人而言，克里过去说的话，有些是不一致的，有些简直就是赤裸裸的谎言。所以，我真的很怀疑。当他说某些话时，我不知道他是否真的相信。
Republican leaning voters in Republican towns are probably inclined to be skeptical of any Democrat to start with, but combine that with the largest television ad campaign in political history-- $2 to $4 million dollars in Republican ads each week in Ohio alone, many of those ads calling Kerry a liar, and a flip-flopper, and a liberal-- the result is, even when Kerry says things that are absolutely true, nobody in the room buys it.
共和党倾向的城镇里的选民起初可能就倾向于怀疑任何民主党人，但这再加上历史上最大的电视广告攻势——仅在俄亥俄州，每周就有200万到400万美元的共和党广告，其中许多广告称克里是骗子、摇摆不定者和自由派——结果就是，即使克里说的是绝对事实，房间里也没人买账。
And because of that, when he lays out a plan, for the economy, for health care, they assume the worst. Gig points out, quite rightly, that John Kerry has still never answered the question from the debate, how would he pay for his health care plan and all the other things he wants to do, and cut the deficit in half, like he promises? He doesn't even believe Kerry's pledge to stick with the war and win the war in Iraq.
正因为如此，当他提出经济或医疗改革计划时，他们都会往最坏处想。吉格非常正确地指出，约翰·克里至今仍未回答辩论中提出的问题：他打算如何为医疗计划和他想做的其他事情买单，并像他承诺的那样将赤字减半？他甚至不相信克里会坚持战争并赢得伊拉克战争的承诺。
No, that's the whole point. That's the whole point I'm making. I think Kerry says things-- that's why I don't like Kerry, because I don't trust him. I don't trust what he says.
不，这才是问题的关键。这正是我所表达的关键。我认为克里说的话……这就是我不喜欢克里的原因，因为我不信任他。我不信任他说的话。
I talked to Gig a lot about who he believed and why in the weeks after the debate. Gig was very aware of the whoppers that the president has told, denying, for example, how badly the war is going, even lying about the number of trained Iraqi security forces during the debates. Or how the president misled the public on the cost of his own prescription drug program. In Gig's view, both candidates lie, the president lies, but even if he lies, Gig feels, the president still has more integrity than John Kerry.
辩论结束后几周里，我经常和吉格聊他信任谁以及原因。吉格非常清楚总统说过的弥天大谎，比如否认战争进行得有多糟糕，甚至在辩论中谎称受过训练的伊拉克安全部队人数。或者总统如何在他自己的处方药计划成本问题上误导公众。在吉格看来，两位候选人都撒谎，总统也撒谎，但即使总统撒谎，吉格觉得，总统依然比约翰·克里更有诚信。
If you come down to, you know, somebody acting on their beliefs, I think Bush is more believable than Kerry. I mean, I think, for instance, Bush will make some decisions that are terribly unpopular, they're phenomenally unpopular-- stem cell research, for instance-- phenomenally unpopular, and he will do it because he believes that's the right thing to do.
如果归根结底到某人是否践行自己的信仰，我认为布什比克里更可信。比如，我认为布什会做出一些非常不受欢迎的决定，简直是极其不受欢迎的，比如干细胞研究，极其不受欢迎，但他会做，因为他相信那是正确的事情。
And I disagree with you, but again I would point out--
我不同意你的观点，但我还是要再次指出——
Well, give me an example.
好吧，给我举个例子。
But again, I would point out to you that you probably agree with Kerry on this issue.
但我要再次指出，在这个问题上你可能和克里观点一致。
On what issue?
什么问题？
Stem cell research.
干细胞研究。
Well, yeah.
嗯，是的。
Yeah.
是啊。
OK, let me just stop the tape of this interview right there. Gig pointed to examples like this one a lot, things where President Bush stuck to his convictions, like invading Iraq, or his tax cut, or stem cell research, and I found this a little confusing coming from Gig.
好了，让我在这里停一下录音。吉格经常指出这类例子，即布什总统坚持信念的事情，比如入侵伊拉克、减税或干细胞研究，我发现吉格的逻辑有点让人困惑。
You know, in all these things where you're saying the President has convictions, and they're unpopular things to do, you don't notice that you side with the other guy. And somehow, you're siding with the president because he's doing something that you don't like. It's crazy jujitsu. You're saying, you know what, you know what I like about that guy, you know why I'm going to vote for him? He take stands that I hate and I disagree with.
你知道，所有这些你说总统有信念且不受欢迎的事情，你难道没注意到你其实是站在另一方的吗？不知为何，你站在总统那边，是因为他在做你不喜欢的事情。这真是疯狂的柔术。你在说，你知道吗，关于那个人我喜欢的是什么，你知道我为什么选他吗？他采取了我不喜欢且不同意的立场。
I can understand how that--
我能理解那——
It seems really crazy.
这看起来真的很疯狂。
That seems odd. I can understand that. No, the reason is, I think-- I don't like Bush. I disagree with a ton of things he does, you're right. I think the thing that you have to have in your president, you have to believe in him. He has to say something, and you have to believe that he is going to do what he says, or that he believes what he says. And I don't agree with what he says a ton of times, but Kerry will not make a hard decision that is unpopular. I believe that.
这确实很奇怪。我能理解。不，原因在于，我想——我不喜欢布什。我同意你的观点，他做的很多事情我都反对。我认为你对总统的要求是，你必须相信他。他说什么，你必须相信他会言出必行，或者他相信自己说的话。虽然我有很多次不同意他说的话，但克里不会做出不受欢迎的艰难决定。我是这么认为的。
But you value that above somebody who's making popular decisions that you agree with?
但你把这看得比那些你同意的、受欢迎的决策更重要吗？
I know, that sounds crazy, doesn't it? But I think Bush has more integrity than Kerry.
我知道，这听起来很疯狂，对吧？但我认为布什比克里更有诚信。
But who cares if he has integrity from your point of view, if he has integrity in supporting policies that you disagree with?
但是，从你的角度来看，如果他支持你反对的政策，他有诚信又有什么意义呢？
Well, that's a very good point.
嗯，这确实是个很好的观点。
In some sense, like, who cares if Kerry is a suck-up? He's a suck-up who's sucking up to you. He wants to do what you want.
某种程度上，克里是不是一个爱拍马屁的人又有什么关系呢？如果他拍马屁的对象是你，他想做你想要的。
That's a very good point. Well, see, I guess that's why I'm still not completely decided. I mean, I think that's an excellent point.
那确实是个很好的观点。好吧，我想这就是我还没完全决定的原因。我认为这是一个极其有力的观点。
You know, it strikes me, you keep saying, if only the Democrats had nominated anybody but Kerry, but don't you think, whoever they nominated, the Republicans would have painted them in some sort of way where you would be saying this about them?
你知道，这让我想到，你一直在说如果民主党提名的不是克里就好了，但你不觉得无论他们提名谁，共和党人都会用某种方式把你描述成这样吗？
No, I do not believe that.
不，我不相信。
How?
怎么说？
No, absolutely not.
不，绝对不会。
But didn't they do exactly the same thing with Clinton? They painted him as a flip-flopper.
但他们在克林顿身上不也用了同样的手法吗？他们把他描绘成一个摇摆不定的人。
They went after Clinton big time.
他们确实大肆攻击克林顿。
Yeah, and on the same grounds.
是啊，也是基于同样的理由。
He was an excellent moderate president. There's an example of a moderate president. He was excellent. He was excellent.
他是一个出色的温和派总统。那是一个温和派总统的例子。他非常出色。他非常出色。
And you want to know why? Because he was a suck-up. Seriously, that's what--
你想知道为什么吗？因为他喜欢拍马屁。说真的，就是这样——
He was, he felt everybody's pain.
他确实如此，他能体会每个人的痛苦。
He did. He wanted to take the popular position, much like John Kerry. That's why he held all the positions that you held. That's why you like him in retrospect. Because all the things that you like, he looked at polling data, and he said, you know what, most people like that, so who cares what I, Bill Clinton, think, I'm just going to be for that stuff.
他做到了。他想采取最受欢迎的立场，这和约翰·克里很像。这就是为什么你回过头来看觉得他很合你的意。因为所有你喜欢的东西，他都看过民调数据，然后他说，你知道吗，大多数人都喜欢那个，所以我才不在乎我比尔·克林顿怎么想，我就是要支持那些东西。
Absolutely, that's right. He tacked to the right. He co-opted a lot of the Republican issues.
绝对没错，他转向了右翼。他吸纳了共和党的许多议题。
OK, so Bill Clinton did that. Bill Clinton basically said, I'm going to look at the polls, I'm going to suck up to whatever the majority of people want. In retrospect, you like him.
好吧，所以比尔·克林顿做到了。比尔·克林顿基本上说，我要看民调，我要拍大多数人想要的马屁。回过头来看，你喜欢他。
In retrospect, I like him a lot.
回顾过去，我很喜欢他。
OK, so if that's what Kerry turns out to be, he'll look at the polls every day, whatever the majority wants, he's going to give it to them. Well, eight more years of peace and prosperity.
好吧，所以如果克里最终成了那样，他每天看民调，无论多数人想要什么，他就给什么。好吧，那就再有八年的和平与繁荣。
Hmm. That's a good point. That's a good point.
嗯。这是一个很好的观点。这确实是个好观点。
My conversations with Gig were a source of fascination for me, and I think for him too, because we agreed on so many things: the war, tax cuts, the deficit, social issues. We agreed that the Bush administration seems incompetent at conducting the war on terror. We agreed that John Kerry doesn't really seem to stand for much, and that when he voted for the war in Iraq, it was probably only because he was scared that voting against it would hurt his presidential ambitions, which shows an alarming lack of conviction on his part.
我和吉格的谈话让我非常着迷，我想他也是，因为我们在很多事情上达成了一致：战争、减税、赤字、社会议题。我们一致认为布什政府在进行反恐战争方面似乎很无能。我们一致认为约翰·克里似乎并没有什么坚定的立场，而且他投票支持伊拉克战争可能只是因为害怕反对会损害他的总统雄心，这显示出他缺乏信念。
We agreed on all of this. And yet, Gig considers himself a Republican, and I consider myself a Democrat. It's perplexing, really. Anyway, weeks pass, more debates, then we get this message on our voicemail here at This American Life.
我们在这一切上都达成了共识。然而，吉格认为自己是共和党人，我却认为自己是民主党人。这真的令人困惑。不管怎样，几周过去了，又进行了几场辩论，然后我们在这里的《美国生活》语音信箱收到了这条留言。
Voice call received Tuesday, October 19.
10月19日星期二收到语音留言。
Hi, this is Gig Hackett. I've come to a final decision that I think is very well-reasoned and I'm comfortable with. I don't know if Ira is going to interview me again. I didn't want to bug him in case he wasn't.
嗨，我是吉格·哈克特。我已经做出了最终决定，我认为这是一个非常理性的决定，我也感到心安。我不知道艾拉是否会再采访我。我只是不想打扰他。
Right, I wouldn't be curious. Of course I call him, and Gig tells me that he's broken it down. On security, he trusts the president more. On the economy, both candidates are promising to cut the deficit by half in four years, and Gig, he doesn't believe either one, but he doesn't believe Kerry more.
没关系，我当然好奇。我当然给他打了电话，吉格告诉我他已经想通了。在安全问题上，他更信任总统。在经济问题上，两位候选人都承诺在四年内将赤字减半，吉格不相信他们任何一个人，但他更不相信克里。
I'm not voting, truly, I'm not voting on the basis of party line. I'm not. I would vote for almost any Democrat over Bush. But they've got the most liberal Democrat in the Senate.
我投票真的不是基于党派路线。真的不是。我几乎会投任何民主党人而不投布什。但他们提名的却是参议院里最自由的民主党人。
But actually Kerry isn't the most liberal Democrat in the Senate.
但其实克里并不是参议院里最自由的民主党人。
He's not?
不是吗？
No. No.
不是。
How can they say that so many times without it being-- well, who is? How do you say that?
他们怎么能这么多次说出这种话而又不是事实呢——好吧，那谁是？你怎么会这么说？
This is an article from the Los Angeles Times.
这是《洛杉矶时报》的一篇文章。
This article, and a similar one that was in The Washington Post, point out that the most liberal label comes from the nonpartisan magazine, the National Journal . But the National Journal itself has said that the label is misleading. As I told Gig, it's based on Kerry's 2003 Senate voting record, when he missed a lot of votes while campaigning. When you look at his full voting record since coming into the Senate, you find that 10 current Senators rate as more liberal in the National Journal .
这篇文章以及《华盛顿邮报》上的一篇类似文章指出，“最自由”的标签来自无党派杂志《国家杂志》。但《国家杂志》本身也表示这个标签具有误导性。正如我告诉吉格的，这是基于克里2003年在参议院的投票记录，当时他因为竞选错过了很多投票。如果你看他进入参议院以来的完整投票记录，你会发现《国家杂志》评定有10位现任参议员比他更自由。
Kerry is liberal, there's no doubt about it, but he supported the Gramm-Rudman-Hollings Balanced Budget Act. He supported free trade. He supported the Clinton welfare reform. All things that liberals oppose. The moderate Democratic Leadership Council counts him as one of their own.
克里是自由派，这是毫无疑问的，但他支持《格拉姆-拉德曼-霍林斯平衡预算案》。他支持自由贸易。他支持克林顿的福利改革。所有这些都是自由派所反对的。温和的民主党领导委员会将他视为他们的一员。
I think that's really interesting. I'll look into it some more.
我觉得这真的很有趣。我会再深入研究一下。
We also talked about Gig's fears of what's going to happen if President Bush is in the White House, and Republicans are controlling the House and the Senate, as they are likely to do again.
我们也谈到了吉格的担忧，如果布什总统留在白宫，而共和党人像往常一样控制众议院和参议院，会发生什么。
That was the biggest stumbling block to voting for Bush, was that very thing.
那正是投票给布什最大的障碍，就是那件事。
So what you're going to have is you're going to have President Bush, and then you'll have a Republican House, a Republican Senate, and then--
所以你会面对布什总统，然后你会有一个共和党控制的众议院、共和党控制的参议院，然后——
I know, I know. See, you're making me feel bad about--
我知道，我知道。看，你让我感觉很糟糕，关于——
You're going to be OK with the one to three-- no, no, just to play this out-- you're going to be OK with the one to three Supreme Court justices who the president will appoint, probably overturn Roe versus Wade. You're good with that, too?
你能接受总统将任命的一到三名最高法院大法官吗？可能会推翻罗诉韦德案。你也觉得这没问题吗？
No, I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I'm getting depressed again. You know, you're right, that is-- these are very good points. I guess it's up in the air again for me. I'm going to have to think about this.
不，我不接受。我不接受。我不接受。我又开始沮丧了。你知道，你说得对，这些都是非常好的观点。我想这一切对我来说又变成悬而未决了。我得好好想想。
After that phone call, Gig decided on Kerry for a few days. And then, after weeks of, dare I say, flip-flopping, he came back to President Bush. I asked him over and over if, in the end, he's a Republican, he just feels more comfortable with the Republican. And he said, no. He said it was all about the issues. In the end, he thinks the president will keep us safer, despite the debacle in Iraq, and despite the fact that he disagrees with them on almost every other issue.
在那次通话后，吉格决定支持克里几天。然后，在几周的——我敢说——左右摇摆之后，他又回到了布什总统这边。我一次又一次地问他，如果他终究是共和党人，他是不是只是觉得共和党人让他更舒服。他说不。他说这一切都是关于议题的。最终，他认为总统会让我们更安全，尽管伊拉克乱成一团，尽管他在几乎所有其他问题上都不同意总统。
Act Two, Cold-Cock The Vote. There are saboteurs targeting undecided voters, and all other voters besides. Some of these things are so outrageous we felt like we had to devote some air time to it this week. Jack Hitt went to Democrats and Republicans alike to review what's happening.
第二幕，击垮投票。有些破坏分子正把矛头指向未决定选民，以及除了他们之外的所有其他选民。其中一些事情简直令人发指，我们觉得本周必须花点时间播报一下。杰克·希特走访了民主党和共和党人，回顾到底发生了什么。
There are already hundreds of alarming stories this election year, and as a public service, I've immersed myself in this hideous sump of pond scum. It's deep here. So deep, that to give you even a bare sense of the sheer profundity of this abyss, I'm going to have to resort to one of the oldest gimmicks in radio broadcasting. That's right, speeded up music.
今年的选举已经有数百起令人担忧的故事，作为一项公共服务，我已经让自己沉浸在这个令人作呕的政治污水池里了。这里的水很深。深到为了让你对这深渊的深度有个初步的概念，我不得不求助于无线电广播中最古老的噱头。没错，就是快放的音乐。
Nevada. Dan Burdish, former director of the state's Republican party, filed a complaint to remove 17,000 voters from the rolls because they had failed to file a change of address card. State law doesn't require it, and in fact, allows you to vote after moving. When asked why he did it, Burdish told the press, I'm looking to take Democrats off the voter rolls.
内华达州。前州共和党主席丹·伯迪什提出投诉，要求从名册中删除17000名选民，理由是他们未能提交地址变更卡。州法律并不要求这样做，事实上，允许你在搬家后投票。当被问及为何这样做时，伯迪什告诉媒体：“我正打算把民主党人从选民名册中剔除。”
Florida. Senior citizens in Democratic precincts are calling their election boards by the hundreds, reporting that strangers, claiming to be from the elections office, are offering to hand-deliver their absentee ballots for them, even though there is no such program.
佛罗里达州。民主党选区的年长市民成百上千地致电选举委员会，举报有陌生人声称来自选举办公室，提出要为他们送缺席选票，尽管根本没有这样的项目。
Wyoming. Secretary of State Joseph Meyer interpreted the statutes there to outlaw voter registration drives, like the kind where a group sets up a card table in a mall or library. One of Meyer's oldest friends, a classmate in both high school and college, is Dick Cheney.
怀俄明州。州务卿约瑟夫·迈耶解释该州法律，将选民登记活动定为非法，比如那种在商场或图书馆设立卡片桌登记选民的行为。迈耶最古老的朋友之一、他高中和大学的同学，就是迪克·切尼。
Philadelphia. Three weeks before the election, a white Republican alderman named Matt Robb requested that 63 polling stations in African-American neighborhoods be relocated, thereby making it more confusing for 37,000 Democrat-leaning voters.
费城。选举前三周，一位名叫马特·罗布的白人共和党市议员要求将非裔美国人社区的63个投票站搬迁，从而让37000名倾向民主党的选民感到困惑。
Florida. Once again, as in the 2000 election, the state compiled a list of felons to be barred from voting. Throughout this election year, Governor Jeb Bush's administration struggled to keep this a secret. After a lawsuit forced it into the open, people quickly saw that, while some 23,000 Democrat-leaning black felons were barred from voting, almost the same number of Hispanic felons in Florida, who tend to vote Republican, were somehow not on the list.
佛罗里达州。再一次，像2000年选举一样，该州编制了一份重罪犯名单，禁止他们投票。在整个选举年，杰布·布什州长的政府竭力对此保密。在一场诉讼迫使其公开后，人们很快发现，虽然约有23000名倾向民主党的黑人重罪犯被禁止投票，但佛罗里达州几乎同样数量的倾向共和党的拉美裔重罪犯不知何故没有出现在名单上。
There are some stories, though, where you really want to slow down and relish the details. Take New Hampshire. On Election Day two years ago, the Democrats offered their voters a hotline to call if they were disabled or aged and needed a ride to the polls. Early in the morning, the phones started ringing continuously, but when the volunteers answered, the callers would hang up. This jammed the lines, and legitimate callers couldn't get through.
不过，有些故事你确实想慢下来细细品味。看看新罕布什尔州。两年前的选举日，民主党人为他们的选民提供了一条热线，供残疾或年长的选民拨打，如果他们需要搭车去投票。清晨，电话铃响个不停，但当志愿者接听时，打电话的人就会挂断。这导致线路堵塞，合法的选民无法拨入。
The Democrats complained to Verizon, which immediately traced every one of the calls to a Virginia company called GOP Marketplace. After a police investigation, the president of that firm, and a former executive director of the New Hampshire Republican party, both pled guilty to criminal charges and admitted that they had hatched the plan to have callers from GOP Marketplace jam the line in order to prevent elderly and disabled Democrats from getting to the polls.
民主党人向威瑞森公司投诉，威瑞森立即追踪到所有电话都来自一家叫GOP Marketplace的弗吉尼亚公司。经过警方调查，该公司总裁和新罕布什尔州共和党前执行主任都认罪了，承认他们策划了让GOP Marketplace的呼叫者堵塞热线的计划，以阻止年长和残疾的民主党人前往投票。
But that's not the end of the story. The court documents refer ominously to an unindicted co-conspirator, a national strategist who arranged the entire dirty trick. The Democrats launched a civil suit to find out how far up the line the order went. In October, the Democrats' lawyer, Steve Gordon, scheduled a routine deposition of one of those involved. 20 minutes before they were all to meet in Gordon's office, a call came in. It was the Justice Department of the United States in Washington, John Ashcroft's office, issuing an emergency halt to the deposition. The deposition would have to be postponed until after the election.
但故事还没结束。法庭文件隐晦地提到了一个未被起诉的共谋者，即安排整个恶作剧的全国策略师。民主党人发起了一场民事诉讼，以查清这一命令的来源有多高层。10月，民主党人的律师史蒂夫·戈登安排了一次相关人员的例行证词。就在他们都要在戈登办公室见面前的20分钟，电话来了。是美国华盛顿特区的司法部，即约翰·阿什克罗夫特的办公室，发布了紧急叫停证词的命令。证词必须推迟到选举之后。
This federal intrusion into local politics was so ham-fisted and extraordinary that it got tongues wagging all over the state. And soon enough, the tongues shook loose the identity of the mystery phone jammer as one of President Bush's top strategists, Jeffery Tobin, the regional director of Bush/Cheney '04 for the entire Northeast. Two weeks ago, he resigned.
这种对地方政治的联邦干预是如此拙劣和不同寻常，以至于在全州引起了议论纷纷。很快，流言传出，这位神秘的电话阻断者就是布什总统的高级策略师之一杰弗里·托宾，他是布什-切尼2004年整个东北地区的地区主任。两周前，他辞职了。
In the past, all these tactics would have been found out by the media weeks after the election, when the perpetrators would be long gone, and the damage done. But this year, the internet is ready. Every day, new accounts of political scamming surface on blogs like Atrios or Daily Kos. There's even an archive of dirty tricks maintained over at [? erepost.com ?].
过去，所有这些策略可能在选举几周后才会被媒体发现，那时肇事者早已远走高飞，损失也已造成。但今年，互联网准备好了。每天，关于政治欺诈的叙述都会出现在Atrios或Daily Kos等博客上。甚至还有一个专门存档恶作剧的网站。
And when you browse these sites, once hidden patterns suddenly appear. It's sort of like how historians say that serial murder was only discovered after the invention of the telegraph, which allowed cops to quickly share evidence. This year, the blogs have allowed us to see, for the very first time, the wide, wide world of serial vote suppression. For example, let's look at the accounts of two librarians who've never met, from opposite sides of the country.
当你浏览这些网站时，隐藏的模式突然显现出来。这有点像历史学家说的，连环杀人案是在电报发明后才被发现的，电报使警察能够迅速分享证据。今年，博客使我们第一次看到了广泛的连环投票压制世界。例如，让我们看看两位从未谋面的图书馆员的故事，她们来自国家的两端。
In September, Megan O'Flaherty, a librarian in Medford, Oregon, got a letter.
9月，俄勒冈州梅德福的一位图书馆员梅根·奥弗莱蒂收到了一封信。
The letter that came to me, it's on Sproul & Associates Incorporated letterhead. "Our firm has been contacted to help coordinate a national nonpartisan voter registration drive. We would like to be able to register people to vote in front of your location."
寄给我的信使用的是Sproul & Associates公司的信笺。“我们公司已被联系以帮助协调一项全国性的无党派选民登记活动。我们希望能在您的地点门前登记选民。”
That name, Sproul & Associates, I want you to remember that. Now let's leave Oregon and fly off to Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, where Holly McCullough, at the Carnegie Library, got a similar request. Nathan Sproul for a nonpartisan registration drive. But things weren't what they seemed. Holly, for example, had patrons complaining that the Sproul workers were quizzing them about who they would vote for.
那个名字，Sproul & Associates，我要你记住。现在离开俄勒冈，飞往宾夕法尼亚州的匹兹堡，卡内基图书馆的霍莉·麦卡洛收到了类似的请求。内森·斯普劳尔要求进行无党派登记活动。但事情并非如此简单。例如，霍莉有读者投诉，说斯普劳尔的工作人员在询问他们投票给谁。
So both Megan and Holly started digging. And here's what they found out. Sproul, it turns out, is a partisan group, run by Nathan Sproul, the former director of the Arizona Republican Party, and the state's Christian Coalition. Sproul has received more than $3 million in contracts this year, from no less than the Republican National Committee, to pump up party registration. And, these last two weeks, Sproul has been popping up everywhere, in as many as 10 states.
所以梅根和霍莉都开始挖掘真相。以下是她们发现的结果：原来，斯普劳尔是一个党派组织，由内森·斯普劳尔运营，他是亚利桑那州共和党和州基督教联盟的前任主任。斯普劳尔今年获得了超过300万美元的合同，来源正是共和党全国委员会，旨在扩大党内注册。而且，过去两周，斯普劳尔到处出现，足迹遍及多达10个州。
Let's soar off to one of them, West Virginia. Lisa Bragg is a temp worker there who signed on with a half dozen other temps for work described as customer service. She remembers it required a day of training.
让我们飞往其中一个州，西弗吉尼亚州。丽莎·布拉格是一名临时工，她和其他半打临时工一起签署了工作合同，工作内容被描述为客户服务。她记得这需要一天的培训。
They presented us with some paperwork, and on one of the papers, on the top of the paper, it says Sproul & Associates. And it's a script, a voter registration script. And it gives you different scenarios, one is for Bush and one is for Kerry, as to how you would speak to people.
他们给了我们一些文书工作，其中一张纸的顶部写着Sproul & Associates。那是一个脚本，一个选民登记脚本。它给出了不同的情景，一个是针对布什的，一个是针对克里的，教你怎么和人交谈。
Do you remember sort of what those scripts were?
你还记得那些脚本大致是什么样的吗？
It's right in front of me. I kept these forms.
就在我面前。我保留了这些表格。
Oh, really? Oh, great. Can you just, like, if you were approaching me on the street, how would you?
哦，真的吗？太好了。你能演示一下，比如你在街上接近我，你会怎么做？
OK. I would say, hello, we are doing a simple survey. If the election were held today, would you vote for President Bush or Senator Kerry? If you were to say Bush, I would say, great, well, this is a very important election year, are you registered to vote at your current residence? If you would say no, I would say, all right, can you please fill out this voter registration form?
好的。我会说，你好，我们正在做一个简单的调查。如果今天举行选举，你会投票给布什总统还是克里参议员？如果你说布什，我会说，太好了，今年是非常重要的选举年，您在目前的住所登记投票了吗？如果你说不，我会说，好的，请您填写这张选民登记表好吗？
If I had said Kerry, what would you have said to me?
如果我说克里，你会对我说什么？
Thank you very much for your time. I will report this.
非常感谢您的时间。我会上报这一情况。
Oh, so you wouldn't hand the person a registration card at all?
哦，所以你根本不会把登记卡交给那个人？
No.
不会。
Lisa says she quit. She didn't like all the secrecy and covert operations involved.
丽莎说她辞职了。她不喜欢其中涉及的所有秘密和隐蔽行动。
On another sheet of paper, it says-- they were telling us, if the media approached us, to go to a pay phone and call this number. They didn't want us talking to the media.
在另一张纸上写着——他们告诉我们，如果媒体接近我们，就去打公用电话，打这个号码。他们不想让我们跟媒体交谈。
And when you called that number, what were you supposed to just say?
当你打那个号码时，你应该只说什么？
The media's coming. The media's coming. I don't know. Stop, the media's here. I don't know. I didn't want to be put in a position like that. Not only was I lying to people about what I was doing, but I was going to hide from the media? That's crazy.
媒体来了，媒体来了。我不知道。停止，媒体在这里。我不知道。我不想陷入那种境地。我不但对人们撒谎我在做什么，还要躲避媒体？这太疯狂了。
OK, Tinkerbell, are you ready to fly off to the next spot? Look, there's Nevada. This week, though, what happens in Vegas isn't staying there. It's the latest chapter in the Sproul story, one that will soon get told in criminal court. A former Sproul worker has hired a lawyer named Paul Larson, who explains the upcoming case.
好了，奇妙仙子，你准备好飞往下一个点了吗？看，那是内华达州。不过这周，在拉斯维加斯发生的事情不会留在那里。这是斯普劳尔故事的最新篇章，很快就会在刑事法庭上讲述。一位前斯普劳尔员工聘请了一位名叫保罗·拉尔森的律师，他解释了即将到来的案件。
This young man didn't do the screening process and just registered everybody who would let him do it. This is according to his sworn affidavit. The organization indicated to him that, we're not paying you to register Democrats, and actually tore up several of them in front of him, which he retrieved from the trash and we provided to the court as exhibits.
这位年轻人没有进行筛选过程，只是登记了所有愿意让他登记的人。这是根据他签署的宣誓书得出的。该组织向他示意说，我们不付钱让你登记民主党人，事实上当着他的面撕毁了几份，他从垃圾桶里找了回来，我们将其作为证据提供给了法庭。
Two more former Sproul workers in Nevada, and others in Oregon, have stepped forward with allegations of more registrations being ripped up. No one knows how many may have been destroyed. So these people, all Democrats, will not be able to vote at all. They think they are registered, and may show up at the polls on Election Day to learn that there is no legal way, provisional ballot or not, that they could vote.
在内华达州和俄勒冈州还有另外两名前斯普劳尔员工挺身而出，指控有更多的注册资料被撕毁。没人知道到底有多少资料被销毁了。所以这些人，全部都是民主党人，将根本无法投票。他们以为自己已经注册了，选举日当天可能出现在投票站，却发现没有任何合法方式（无论是否有临时选票）可以让他们投票。
In response to the Sproul story, Republicans in Nevada have said that Democrats engage in similar tactics. Chris Carr, the executive director of the state party, made public three Democrat registration forms with nonexistent addresses. This is the way these stories go. Both sides make charges that seem roughly the same, but on this issue, there is a qualitative difference between Democrats and Republicans. I called both camps and asked them to give me their worst stuff about the other side. Here's what the Republican spokesman, Scott Hogenson, said.
针对斯普劳尔的故事，内华达州的共和党人表示民主党也从事类似的策略。该州党部执行主任克里斯·卡尔公开了三份带有不存在地址的民主党登记表。故事总是这样发展的。双方都提出看似大致相同的指控，但在这个问题上，民主党和共和党之间存在质的差异。我给两个阵营都打了电话，要求他们提供关于对方最恶劣的事例。以下是共和党发言人斯科特·霍根森所说的话。
We have been compiling hundreds of pages of media reports from all over the country of documented cases, of investigations, of fraudulent voter registration cases, everything from police in Ohio investigating a pro-Kerry effort to submit faulty voter registration forms and pay the people with crack cocaine, to a gentleman in Denver, Colorado, who brags and laughs on television about having registered to vote 35 times. The number and degree of faulty, and questionable, and outright fraudulent registrations is really quite stunning in its depth and breadth.
我们一直在汇编全国各地的数百页媒体报道，记录了欺诈性选民登记案件的调查，从俄亥俄州警方调查支持克里的组织通过支付快克毒品报酬来提交虚假选民登记表，到丹佛的一位先生在电视上吹嘘并嘲笑自己登记投票了35次。错误、可疑和彻底欺诈的注册数量和程度在深度和广度上确实非常令人震惊。
He sent me a copy. It's all newspaper clips, many of them unverified charges. There are a few that check out. There really was, for example, this white guy working for an outfit affiliated with the NAACP, who registered voters under names like Mary Poppins and Jeffrey Dahmer. And it's true, he was paid in crack cocaine. Very bad, and a great story.
他寄给我一份副本。全部都是报纸剪报，其中许多是未经核实的指控。有几个确实查实了。例如，确实有这个为NAACP附属机构工作的白人，以“玛丽·波平斯”和“杰弗里·达默”之类的名字登记选民。而且是真的，他被支付了快克毒品作为报酬。非常糟糕，也是一个伟大的故事。
And then there was the Colorado guy who registered himself 35 times. Also true, also very bad. But the reason you're going to be hearing about these two examples over and over in the official Republican talking points in the next few days is that that's the best they've got in their hundreds of pages. Strange enough, reading the very stories they sent often undercut their main argument.
还有那个登记了35次的科罗拉多州人。也是真的，也非常糟糕。但你接下来几天会反复听到这些事例的原因是，这已经是他们数百页资料中最好的了。奇怪的是，阅读他们寄来的报道本身往往削弱了他们的主要论点。
For example, that Colorado guy, here's a line from the article the GOP sent me. Quote, "Just because you register someone 35 times doesn't mean they vote 35 times," end quote. Let me repeat. These are quotes from the official Republican vote fraud press packet.
例如，那个科罗拉多州的人，这是共和党寄给我的文章中的一行。引用：“仅仅因为你登记了某人35次，并不意味着他们投票了35次。”结束引用。让我重复一遍。这些是来自官方共和党投票欺诈新闻包的引语。
Where there are real cases of registration fraud in this compendium, they usually involve poor people getting caught, not trying to fix the vote, but trying to squeeze a few extra bucks, or, OK, a nice chunk of crack, out of these organizations that stupidly pay the temps a fee for each registration card turned in. But don't take my word for it. Again, the GOP's own clip file. Registration irregularities are, quote, "Not an attempt to commit fraud, but rather the result of greedy workers who get paid for every voter they sign up, or already registered voters who forget and register again," end quote.
在这些汇编中确实存在真正的注册欺诈案例，它们通常涉及贫困人口被抓住，不是试图操纵投票，而是试图从这些愚蠢地为每份提交的注册卡支付临时工费用的组织那里多赚点钱，或者仅仅是为了那块快克毒品。但别听我的一面之词，还是看共和党自己的剪报。注册违规行为引用：“并非试图实施欺诈，而是贪婪的工人为了每注册一个选民就获得报酬，或者是已经注册的选民忘记了而再次注册的结果。”结束引用。
Meanwhile, the incidents of vote suppression on the Republican side involve massive numbers, and soon enough, actual jail time for high-ranking officials connected directly to the party. Chuck McGee, the executive director of the New Hampshire GOP, is scheduled to be sentenced. Sproul is awaiting trial. Then this Florida's felony purge list, which almost knocked 23,000 African-Americans off the voting rolls, while keeping arguably the same number of Republican-leaning felons free to vote.
与此同时，共和党方面的投票压制事件涉及大量人数，很快就会让直接与该党有关的高级官员入狱。新罕布什尔州共和党执行主任查克·麦基预定接受判刑。斯普劳尔等待审判。还有佛罗里达州的重罪犯清洗名单，差点将23000名非裔美国人从选民名册中剔除，同时让几乎同样数量的倾向共和党的重罪犯自由投票。
Recently, the Sarasota Herald Tribune broke the story that Governor Jeb Bush, the president's brother, ordered the state to proceed with the felony purge list, even though the database company that put it altogether informed him that it was so hopelessly flawed he should, quote, "Pull the plug."
最近，《萨拉索塔先驱论坛报》爆料说，总统的兄弟杰布·布什州长命令该州继续执行重罪犯清洗名单，尽管汇编该名单的数据库公司通知他，名单漏洞百出，他应该引用：“拔掉插头。”
So are they all the same? Is the crackhead faking a handful of registrations for Jeffrey Dahmer the same kind of thing as wiping 17,000 voters in Nevada, 23,000 voters in Florida, 30,000 voters in Ohio completely off the rolls? The other part of the ground war that's being waged this weekend is to make you think that they are.
所以他们都一样吗？那个为了杰弗里·达默伪造少量注册的瘾君子，和在内华达州删除17000名选民、在佛罗里达州删除23000名选民、在俄亥俄州彻底删除30000名选民的行径是一回事吗？在这个周末进行的地面战的另一部分，就是要让你认为他们是一回事。
Jack Hitt in New Haven. Remember this number when you're voting if anybody tries any of these tricks on you, 866-OUR-VOTE. Dozens of democracy-loving lawyers standing by for free to help you. 866-OUR-VOTE.
杰克·希特在纽黑文。当你投票时如果有人尝试任何这些诡计，请记住这个号码，866-OUR-VOTE。数十名热爱民主的律师随时待命，免费为您提供帮助。866-OUR-VOTE。
Coming up, a Navy recruit has to decide on who his next boss will be, that is, who the Commander-in-Chief will be. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一名海军新兵必须决定谁将是他的下一任老板，也就是谁将是三军统帅。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program in this election week, undecided voters and others. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, One Son, One Vote. Now an undecided voter who is just 18 years old, in the tiny town of Selma, Indiana, outside of Muncie. He just graduated high school and signed up for the Navy, hoping to become a Navy SEAL and fight in the war on terror. He doesn't follow politics. He's voting for the first time. His three big political influences, in no particular order, are TV, his brother, and his mom.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在这个选举周，节目主题是未决定选民及其他人。我们现在进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，一个儿子，一票。现在是一位年仅18岁的未决定选民，在蒙西市外一个小镇塞尔玛，印第安纳州。他刚高中毕业并报名参加了海军，希望能成为一名海军海豹突击队队员，并在反恐战争中战斗。他不关注政治。他是第一次投票。他的三大政治影响（无特定顺序）是电视、他兄弟和他妈妈。
OK, TV you know. His brother was part of the invading forces that went into Iraq, served there until last August, now he's a financial adviser in Washington, DC. His mom is a nurse at a VA hospital and a major in the Air Force Reserve. She's volunteered to go into Iraq next year. One of the two is for Bush, one is for Kerry, TV is no help, which leaves Matthew in a pretty uncommitted place. Sarah Koenig dropped in to see how the decision making is going in this, Matthew's first presidential election.
电视你懂的。他兄弟曾是入侵伊拉克的部队成员，去年八月前一直在那里服役，现在是华盛顿特区的一名财务顾问。他妈妈是退伍军人医院的护士，也是空军预备役的少校。她已经志愿明年去伊拉克。两人中一个支持布什，一个支持克里，电视毫无帮助，这让马修处于一个相当摇摆的位置。萨拉·科尼格顺道来看看马修的第一次总统选举决策进展如何。
When I get to his house, it's around five in the evening on the day of the first presidential debate, and the ever encouraged youth vote is sitting on the sofa. The TV is on, a skateboarding show, but he's not really watching. Instead, he's inspecting a large mechanical disk that looks like, and in fact is, a robot.
我到他家时，大约是首场总统辩论当天的傍晚五点，备受关注的青年选民正坐在沙发上。电视开着，正放着滑板节目，但他没怎么看。相反，他正在检查一个看起来像（事实上确实是）机器人的大型机械圆盘。
I'm picking the string out of this Roomba because it's-- you know what this is?
我正在把线从这个Roomba吸尘器里挑出来，因为——你知道这是什么吗？
No I don't, what is it?
不，不知道，这是什么？
They roam around the house vacuuming, but I got it caught on this roll of string when I left it today, so now I've got to take it all out.
它们在屋里到处转悠清理，但我今天不小心让它卷进了一卷线里，所以我现在得把它弄出来。
If you talk to Matthew for a few minutes, you realize he's the perfect person for a vacuum that doesn't require you to get off the couch to use it. He's 18, living in his mom's house for the moment. He's not working. His job, he says, is getting in shape before basic training. His mom leaves him lists of things to do: clean his room, peel potatoes and put them in the crock pot, turn on the crock pot. But he kind of ignores the lists, he says.
如果你和马修聊几分钟，你会发现他是个完美的人选，适合不需要你下沙发就能操作的真空吸尘器。他18岁，目前住在妈妈家里。他没工作。他说他的工作是在基础训练前锻炼身体。他妈妈给他留下待办事项清单：打扫房间、削土豆并放进慢炖锅、打开慢炖锅。但他基本无视了这些清单，他说。
I'm more of a lazy, kind of, try to get away with things.
我比较懒，那种试图偷懒的人。
He's one of those undecided voters who's undecided because he doesn't follow politics. But his mother and brother have very strong opinions about politics. They spend hours on the phone debating, tossing around phrases like up-armored humvees, and intercontinental ballistic missile shields, and Donnie Rumsfeld. It's a little like those Sunday morning politics shows.
他就是那种因为不关注政治而还没决定的选民。但他母亲和兄弟对政治有非常强烈的看法。他们花几个小时在电话里争论，抛出像“加固装甲的悍马”、“洲际弹道导弹防御系统”和“唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德”这样的词汇。这有点像那些周日早晨的政治节目。
I heard Kerry say-- and I thought this was a terrible thing to say-- he's going to pull all the troops out within three months of him being elected.
我听到克里说——我觉得那话说的太糟糕了——他说他当选后三个月内就会撤出所有军队。
He didn't say that. He said that he anticipated that they could begin the process.
他没那么说。他说他预计他们可以开始那个过程。
And so, whenever the terrorists that are over there hear that, they think, oh, all we have to do is hang in here for six more months and we're home free.
所以，无论什么时候在那边的恐怖分子听到这话，他们都会想，哦，我们只要再坚持六个月，我们就安全了。
Well, it's worth noting that the Iraqis--
嗯，值得注意的是，伊拉克人——
Don't get TV?
没电视看？
Actually they do get TV. It's shocking.
实际上他们确实有电视。这太让人震惊了。
Yeah, that's the problem. So I think that that just makes them think, we can hang in there, and I feel like he put soldiers' lives in danger saying that.
是啊，这就是问题所在。所以我认为这只会让他们觉得，我们可以坚持下去，而且我觉得他说那话把士兵的生命置于危险之中。
Overall, the Chasteens are a pretty typical Midwestern, Bible Belt family. Monica worked incredibly hard and raised her three sons in a comfortable, one-story house, with a big backyard bordered by a cornfield and a flag out front. They all went to the Nazarene church. David, the oldest, is 26 now. As a kid, all of his friends were from church. He didn't listen to secular music or swear.
总体来说，Chasteen一家是相当典型的中西部、圣经地带家庭。莫妮卡工作极其努力，抚养了三个儿子，住在一个舒适的单层房子里，后院很大，边缘是一片玉米地，前面挂着一面旗帜。他们都去了拿撒勒派教堂。长子戴维现在26岁了。小时候，他所有的朋友都来自教堂。他不听世俗音乐，也不说脏话。
And like many people in his family, he thought joining the military was the right thing to do, the honorable thing to do. Plus, his family didn't have money for him to go to college, and there aren't that many good jobs in Indiana. And in 2000, he liked George Bush for president. He gave money to the campaign, and he put a bumper sticker on his car. He especially liked the idea of compassionate conservatism.
而且像他家里的许多人一样，他认为加入军队是正确的事情，光荣的事情。此外，他家里没有钱让他去上大学，印第安纳州也没那么多好工作。在2000年，他喜欢乔治·布什当总统。他为竞选捐了钱，还在车上贴了保险杠贴纸。他特别喜欢“富有同情心的保守派”这一想法。
I remember the State of the Union after September 11, where Bush came out and said, we're going to do the hard right over the easy wrong. And the hard right is we're going to send special forces guys into these holes where these Al Qaeda guys are hanging out. We're going to kill them. And then we're going to double the size of the Peace Corps, and we're going to send young Americans out into the Middle East to demonstrate to the rest of the world that we're the good guys, and that we're here to help, and that we're not here to invade, we just want to make the world a better place.
我还记得911事件后的国情咨文，布什出来说，我们要坚持正确的艰难之路，而不是错误的简单之路。正确的艰难之路就是我们要派特种部队进入这些基地组织分子潜伏的洞穴。我们要干掉他们。然后我们要将和平队的规模扩大一倍，我们要派年轻的美国人去中东，向世界其他地方证明我们是好人，我们是来帮忙的，而不是来入侵的，我们只想让世界变得更美好。
And I remember, at that moment, I was talking to my wife about it, and I'm like, right there, that's the President Bush that I voted for. That's a brilliant idea. And in that moment I was so glad that I had voted for him.
我还记得在那一刻，我正和妻子谈论这件事，我就想，就是那一刻，那就是我投票支持的布什总统。那是个绝妙的想法。就在那一刻，我真庆幸自己投了他。
But then the president started talking about invading Iraq, which David thought was, and I quote here, "insane." He thought they should stay focused on Al Qaeda in Afghanistan. David was in the Third Infantry division, which would be the first to invade Iraq. He was a specialist in weapons of mass destruction. He saw the official intelligence on those weapons.
但后来总统开始谈论入侵伊拉克，戴维觉得那简直是（引用此处）“疯了”。他认为他们应该专注于阿富汗的基地组织。戴维在第三步兵师，那是第一支入侵伊拉克的部队。他是大规模杀伤性武器方面的专家。他看过关于这些武器的官方情报。
So I start looking at the intelligence, which comes from the CIA and the DIA. And the analysis all said the same thing, which is, we're pretty sure they have chemical weapons, but we're real sure they're not a threat to the United States. Basically, the argument was Saddam Hussein is a little goofy in the gills, but he's a rational actor. We know what he wants. And what he wants is to stay in power. Nothing would guarantee him losing control of his country faster than using chemical weapons against the United States, or helping a third party use chemical weapons against the United States.
所以我开始查阅情报，那些来自中央情报局和国防情报局的情报。分析都说同样的事情，即我们相当确定他们有化学武器，但我们非常确定他们对美国没有威胁。基本上，论点是萨达姆·侯赛因有点疯狂，但他是个理性行为者。我们知道他想要什么。他想要的是保持权力。没有什么比对他国或支持第三方对美国使用化学武器更能保证他失去国家控制权了。
There's a long way between that and a mushroom cloud in Iowa, which was always the implication of the Bush administration. I remember sitting on the border of Kuwait, jokingly telling my commanding officer the day before the invasion, I'm still holding out for a diplomatic solution.
从那到爱荷华州的蘑菇云还有很长一段路，而那总是布什政府的暗示。我记得坐在科威特边境，入侵前一天开玩笑地告诉我的指挥官，我还在坚持寻求外交解决方案。
He met CIA officers who told him they'd been pulled off looking for Al Qaeda to come to Iraq. He saw Iraqi kids whose legs had been blown off. And he saw the Peace Corps' budget cut, rather than doubled, as President Bush had promised. The problem is that on almost every other issue but Iraq-- taxes, abortion, the role of government in general-- David disagrees with John Kerry. But he's planning on voting for him anyway.
他遇到了中情局官员，他们告诉他他们被从寻找基地组织的工作中调走来伊拉克。他看到了腿被炸断的伊拉克孩子。而且他看到和平队的预算被削减了，而不是像布什总统承诺的那样翻倍。问题是，除了伊拉克问题——税收、堕胎、政府在一般情况下的角色——在几乎所有其他议题上，戴维都不同意约翰·克里的观点。但他还是打算投给他。
I want to vote for Bush so bad. I want to vote for Bush the candidate. But he's just a completely different president than he was in 2000, than the guy that I voted for originally.
我太想投票给布什了。我想投票给布什这位候选人。但他与2000年时完全是不同的总统，不是我最初投票支持的那个人。
That's about as pro-Kerry as it gets in Matthew's house. In the other corner, in the red trunks, is their mom, Monica, a tiny, attractive woman with long blond hair. She's on the official presidential prayer team, which means she gets notices through church or the internet to pray for the president's health and safety, and that he will be surrounded by wise counselors.
在马修家里，这就是对克里最正面的评价了。在另一个角落，戴着红色拳击短裤的是他们的妈妈莫妮卡，一个娇小迷人、有着长长金发的女性。她属于官方总统祈祷团队，这意味着她通过教堂或互联网收到通知，为总统的健康和安全祈祷，并祈祷他被睿智的顾问环绕。
She doesn't know yet when she'll be deployed to Iraq next year, but she's also really disturbed by the war, not so much why we attacked in the first place, but how it's been managed: on the cheap, with bad planning, too few supplies. She's outraged by this story she heard during her training about medical people over there, people like her, who had to choose to let someone die because they didn't have enough IV fluid.
她还不知道明年什么时候会被部署到伊拉克，但她也对战争感到非常不安，不是因为我们最初为什么要攻击，而是因为它是如何管理的：吝啬、规划糟糕、物资太少。她对她在培训期间听到的关于那里医务人员的故事感到愤怒，像她那样的人，不得不选择让某人死去，因为他们没有足够的静脉输液。
But she doesn't wholly blame the president for all that. She blames his advisers. She thinks Secretary Rumsfeld should be fired. David's been lobbying her to consider Kerry, flooding her with emails, but she can't vote for Kerry, or for any pro-choice candidate, period. And she actually thinks David is the one who might reconsider.
但她并不完全怪罪总统，她怪罪他的顾问。她认为拉姆斯菲尔德部长应该被解雇。戴维一直在游说她考虑克里，用电子邮件淹没她，但她不能投票给克里，或任何支持堕胎权的候选人，绝对不行。而且她其实觉得戴维才是那个可能重新考虑的人。
If anyone budges, it'll be David.
如果有人动摇，那肯定是戴维。
I want to budge. I want to budge so badly. But you know.
我想动摇。我太想动摇了。但你知道。
Yeah, it'll be David. For one thing, his mother's praying for him, that the Lord will give him wisdom.
是的，肯定是戴维。首先，他妈妈在为他祈祷，祈求上帝赐予他智慧。
Well, I think your prayers have been answered.
嗯，我想你的祈祷已经得到了回应。
And then there's Matthew, a sweet, dreamy kid, with huge brown eyes, who's afraid to be home alone at night on his quiet country street, and who loves animals.
还有马修，一个甜美、爱做梦的孩子，有着巨大的棕色眼睛，害怕晚上独自待在安静的乡村街道上，而且他热爱动物。
Neptune.
海王星。
His cat.
他的猫。
Daisy.
黛西。
A friend's dog. Anyhow, this is the same Matthew who sleeps with a machete by his side for protection, and wants to go fight in Iraq someday as a Navy SEAL. When it comes to this year's election, Matthew is so new to it all, when I ask him about the political parties, he kind of gets them backwards.
朋友的狗。不管怎样，这就是同一个马修，他晚上睡觉时身边放着一把弯刀来防身，并希望有一天能作为海豹突击队员去伊拉克打仗。当谈到今年的选举时，马修对这一切太陌生了，当我问他关于政党的问题时，他有点把它们搞反了。
But what's interesting is that even someone as politically unplugged as him is getting information, not always perfectly, but still, it's trickling in. So he doesn't know exactly how a bill becomes a law, but he knows George Bush's spotty National Guard record. And he's not quite sure what the president does for a living, but he knows that Kerry served in Vietnam, and that he protested afterward.
但有趣的是，即使是像他这样政治脱节的人也在获取信息，虽然不总是完美的，但信息仍在渗入。所以他不知道法案是如何成为法律的，但他知道乔治·布什斑点斑斑的国民警卫队记录。他也不太确定总统是靠什么维持生计的，但他知道克里在越南服役过，而且他后来参加过抗议。
I don't think it's right just to vote out a president just because, you know, things aren't going our way really. I think he deserves longer than four years to kind of get what he needs to get done. But then again, that might be a huge mistake.
我不认为仅仅因为事情没有按照我们的方式进行就投掉一个总统是正确的。我认为他应该得到比四年更长的时间来完成他需要做的事情。但话又说回来，那可能是一个巨大的错误。
He's anti-abortion, he doesn't like the Patriot Act, but mainly, he wants to vote for the man he likes better, the one who's just a better, smarter person. And his mom and David haven't been exactly helpful as he tries to figure out which one that is.
他是反堕胎的，不喜欢《爱国者法案》，但主要是，他想投票给那个他更喜欢的人，那个更好、更聪明的人。而他妈妈和戴维在努力找出那个人是谁时，并没有提供多少真正的帮助。
They lay out the facts in the best way they can to make whatever they want you to be convinced of sound very good, and everything else just sound ridiculous.
他们用他们能做到的最好方式列出事实，使任何他们想让你信服的事情听起来都很好，而其他所有事情听起来都很荒谬。
So what's an issue where they've done that for you?
那么，有什么议题他们为你这样做过？
Well, one thing, and I'm still not sure, is Dave feeds me a good story about John Kerry's war record. And from what I've seen on TV, what he said was about right. And then I mention it to Mom, and Mom says, oh, he only served a month. And he killed women and children, and he ratted out all of his comrades.
嗯，有一件事，我还不确定，戴夫给我讲了一个关于约翰·克里战争记录的好故事。从我在电视上看到的来看，他说的大致是对的。然后我向妈妈提到它，妈妈说，哦，他只服役了一个月。而且他杀死了妇女和儿童，他还告发了他所有的战友。
And, you know, they'll argue and say, you're wrong, you're wrong, you're stupid, you're stupid, or something like that. And then, all right, I'm going to bed, I love you, good night. And they hang up. And I just kind of listen.
然后，他们会争吵并说，你错了，你错了，你真傻，你真傻，诸如此类的话。然后，好吧，我要去睡觉了，我爱你，晚安。然后他们挂断了电话。我只是听着。
Good evening from the University of Miami Convocation Center in Coral Gables, Florida.
晚上好，来自佛罗里达州科勒尔盖布尔斯的迈阿密大学毕业典礼中心。
They're on, Mom.
他们开始了，妈妈。
--to the first of the 2004 presidential debates.
——2004年首场总统辩论。
All of us sat on the sofa watching. Monica agreed with a lot of things Kerry said about the war, but disagreed with other things.
我们所有人都坐在沙发上观看。莫妮卡同意克里关于战争的许多说法，但不同意其他说法。
When you know something's going wrong, you make it right. That's what I learned in Vietnam. And I'm going to lead those troops to victory.
当你发现某事出问题时，你要纠正它。这就是我在越南学到的。我将带领那些部队走向胜利。
You know, we didn't have a victory in Vietnam, and I really think that Kerry would end this war the same way Vietnam was ended, which Vietnam was the only war we've lost. So he may get us out, but I don't think he'll get us out victoriously.
你知道，我们在越南没有取得胜利，我真的认为克里会以越南结束的方式结束这场战争，越南是我们输掉的唯一一场战争。所以他可能会带我们撤出，但我不认为他会带我们胜利撤出。
Matthew was completely silent during the debate. I thought he wasn't paying much attention. At one point, he wrapped himself in a comforter and put on a winter hat with ear flaps, and I was sure he was going to fall asleep. But when it was over, it was clear he'd been listening closely.
马修在辩论期间完全保持沉默。我以为他没怎么注意。有一次，他把自己裹在被子里，戴上了一个有耳罩的冬帽，我确定他要睡着了。但当辩论结束时，很明显他一直在仔细听。
I was really impressed by Kerry through the whole thing. I like the fact that he had mentioned something about trying to build the special forces, kind of trying to change our tactics on how we're fighting these people. And Bush just kind of sounded like an idiot, I thought, most of the time, just stuttering and he kept repeating himself. Kerry seems like he was a lot more competent, a lot sharper. I just liked him a lot more, just from listening to him talk.
克里在整个过程中真的给我留下了深刻印象。我喜欢他提到了关于尝试建立特种部队的事情，尝试改变我们与这些人作战的战术。而布什大多时候听起来像个白痴，只是结结巴巴，不断重复自己。克里看起来要干练得多，敏锐得多。我只是从听他说话中就更喜欢他了。
Did you get bored sometimes?
你有时会感到无聊吗？
Yeah, I got real bored when I was listening to Bush.
是的，听布什说话时我真的感到很无聊。
Really? Really, like Kerry actually held your interest and Bush didn't?
真的吗？真的就像克里实际上吸引了你的兴趣而布什没有吗？
Yeah. I always played with the cats while Bush was talking.
是的。布什说话时我总是玩猫。
Do you feel like if you end up going to Iraq, you'd feel safer and sort of in better hands if Kerry were president?
你觉得如果你最终去伊拉克，如果克里当总统，你会感到更安全、更放心吗？
Yeah. Because I believe he said that he's in favor of sending more troops there, which means, the more troops we have the safer we are. If I'm over there fighting, I'd definitely like to have better supplies and more guys watching my back.
是的。因为我相信他说过他支持在那里部署更多部队，这意味着我们的部队越多，我们越安全。如果我在那边战斗，我绝对希望能有更好的补给和更多的人支持我。
We called David, and he and his mom argued for nearly an hour about the Nuclear Test Ban Treaty, about whether Kerry could pay for his proposals. Monica asked David if we would lose Iraq the same way we lost Vietnam if Kerry became president. David told her we'd already lost Iraq.
我们给戴维打了电话，他和妈妈争论了将近一个小时，关于核试验禁令条约，关于克里是否能为他的提议买单。莫妮卡问戴维，如果克里当选总统，我们是否会像输掉越南那样输掉伊拉克。戴维告诉她，我们已经输掉了伊拉克。
At the end of the night, though, David was so happy with Kerry's performance that he said, for the first time, he could vote for him with confidence. Matthew was for Kerry, too, but he said he'd keep his mind open a crack for President Bush, and watch the next debates. Monica said she still supported the president, but in a wobbly sort of way.
不过，那天晚上结束时，戴维对克里的表现非常高兴，他说，这是他第一次能自信地投票给他。马修也支持克里，但他表示他会为布什总统留下一丝缝隙，看接下来的辩论。莫妮卡说她仍然支持总统，但立场有些动摇。
This week, nearly a month later, I talked to all three of them again. David was holding steady. Monica says she was considering not voting for president for the first time in her life. The sudden news of that 360-ton pile of explosives found missing in Iraq had especially ticked her off. And Matthew? In the space of one month, he'd gone from a Kerry leaner to an anti-Bush zealot. He sent me an email-- more like a screed-- after he'd seen the Michael Moore movie.
本周，将近一个月后，我再次采访了他们三人。戴维立场坚定。莫妮卡说她正考虑一生中第一次不在总统选举中投票。伊拉克丢失的那360吨爆炸物的突发新闻让她特别生气。马修呢？在一个月内，他从一个克里的支持者变成了一个反布什的狂热分子。他给我发了一封电子邮件——更像是一篇抨击文章——在他看完迈克尔·摩尔的电影之后。
Here's part of what he wrote. "This man should never have taken a step in the White House in the first place, and it is our responsibility to make sure he doesn't ever take another step in it again after election night. With all this swirling in my brain, I'm forced to second guess the wisdom of adding my name to a group of poor fools fighting this weird personal vendetta in the Middle East. What sort of punishments will be laid down if I take a stand?"
以下是他写的一部分。“这个男人根本就不应该踏进白宫，我们有责任确保他在选举之夜后永远不会再踏进去一步。在这一切在我大脑中盘旋时，我被迫重新思考，把我的名字加入一群在世界各地为中东那场奇怪的个人仇恨而战的可怜笨蛋中，究竟是否明智。如果我表明立场，会受到什么样的惩罚？”
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show.
萨拉·科尼格是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Four, He's Got Legs. Now our preview of the coming ground war on Election Day. We end today's program with someone trying to convince the unconvinced and get the convinced to the polls in Columbus, Ohio. Lisa Pollak has the story.
第四幕，他有双腿。现在是对即将到来的选举日地面战的预告。我们以某人为在哥伦布拉票的人，试图说服未决定者并让已决定者去投票，来结束今天的节目。丽莎·波拉克讲述这个故事。
Andy Mills is in his house, getting ready for his first day of door-to-door canvassing. He's never done anything like this before, and he's a little nervous about it. In his regular life, Andy is a college professor, used to speaking in front of audiences, never at a loss for words. But he doesn't like selling things, or the idea of intruding on people at home, asking nosy questions.
安迪·米尔斯在他家里，准备开始他第一天的上门拉票。他以前从未做过这样的事，而且他对此有点紧张。在日常生活中，安迪是一名大学教授，习惯在观众面前演讲，从来不缺词。但他不喜欢卖东西，也不喜欢闯入别人家里提问的这种想法。
Luckily, MoveOn PAC, the anti-Bush group that Andy's canvassing for, has given him a script-- the rap, they call it-- to help him know what to say today. He's been practicing the rap all morning, playing both sides, alone in the kitchen. And before we leave, I make him do it for me without the script.
幸运的是，MoveOn PAC（安迪为其拉票的反布什组织）给了他一个脚本——他们称之为“即兴说唱”——帮助他知道今天该说什么。他整个上午都在练习这个说唱，在厨房里独自扮演双方。在我们离开之前，我让他脱稿为我演示一遍。
OK, so I guess I'm supposed to knock on your door. And then, hi, is Lisa home? And then she'd say yes. I'm Andrew Mills, and I live in the neighborhood, and I'm working on the upcoming election, and I wondered if you've decided who you're going to vote for for president? And they'll say, John Kerry. And I'll say, oh, that's great, that's great. Well, I'm working with MoveOn PAC, and we're just collecting names and some contact information for Kerry voters for our Get Out the Vote campaign, I wondered if you would-- great, yeah, sure.
好的，所以我想你应该敲我的门。然后，嗨，丽莎在家吗？然后她会说在家。我是安德鲁·米尔斯，我住在这个社区，我正在为即将到来的选举工作，我想知道你决定总统选谁了吗？他们会说约翰·克里。然后我会说，哦，太棒了，太棒了。嗯，我和MoveOn PAC一起工作，我们正在为我们的“去投票”运动收集克里支持者的姓名和联系信息，我想知道你是否愿意——太好了，对，当然。
Going real well.
进展得非常好。
It's going well. It's great. In the kitchen it's fantastic.
进行得很顺利。很棒。在厨房里太棒了。
For voters who prefer the president, the rap is just a sentence, thanks, and have a nice day. And if they're undecided, well, the rap doesn't offer as much guidance here. No talking points on the war, no arguments about health care, no secret formula for closing the deal.
对于倾向于总统的选民，说唱只是一句话，谢谢，祝你有愉快的一天。如果他们还没决定，嗯，说唱在这方面提供的指导就不多了。没有战争谈话要点，没有关于医疗保健的争论，也没有促成交易的秘诀。
Hadn't role played that as much as the easy one. But, so, have you decided who you're going to vote for for president? No, I haven't really made up my mind. Well, can I ask you what issues are important to you in the election? And I don't know really where to go from there.
没像简单的那个练得那么多。但是，所以，你决定好总统投给谁了吗？不，我还没真正做出决定。嗯，我能问问你这次选举中什么议题对你很重要吗？我真的不知道从那里该怎么谈。
We head to Andy's assigned precinct, only five minutes from his house, a leafy neighborhood near the Ohio State campus. There are more Buckeye football banners than either Kerry or Bush signs. Andy's anxious to talk to his first non-imaginary voter.
我们前往安迪分配的选区，离他家只有五分钟路程，俄亥俄州立大学附近的一个叶茂密的社区。那里的七叶树足球横幅比克里或布什的标志要多。安迪迫不及待地想和他的第一个非想象中的选民交谈。
Well, this one's 2286.
嗯，这一个是2286。
This is easier said than done.
说起来容易做起来难。
This one looks vacant. Yeah, I don't think anyone's living here.
这个看起来是空的。是的，我不认为有人住在这里。
As we continue down the block, it becomes clear that many of the people on the MoveOn list have in fact moved on.
当我们继续走下去时，很明显MoveOn名单上的许多人实际上已经搬走了。
Hi, is Cindy here? Does she not live here anymore? She moved on. OK, thanks. Is Kyle or Greg here? No, do they not live here? OK, I just have an old voter registration list. Hey, hi. Hi, is Michael or Nathan here? They're not? They don't live here anymore?
嗨，辛迪在家吗？她不住这儿了吗？她搬走了。好的，谢谢。凯尔或格雷格在家吗？不，他们不住这儿吗？好吧，我只是有一份旧的选民名单。嘿，嗨。嗨，迈克尔或内森在家吗？他们不在吗？他们不住这儿了吗？
At house after house, people come to the door. Statistically speaking, some of them must be voters, yet Andy does nothing to plug his candidate, or even start a conversation.
在一户又一户人家，人们来到门口。从统计学上讲，他们中有些人一定是选民，但安迪并没有采取任何行动来推销他的候选人，甚至没有开始对话。
I'm doing some canvassing for the election, do you have a second to talk?
我正在为选举做一些拉票工作，你有时间谈谈吗？
Actually, I'm kind of in the middle of some homework.
事实上，我正在做家庭作业。
In the middle of some homework? OK, no problem. Thanks. Bye. I've got to respect that, being a professor. Working on homework.
在做家庭作业？好吧，没问题。谢谢。再见。作为一个教授，我必须尊重这一点。在做家庭作业。
Do you believe it?
你相信吗？
He didn't look like he was in the middle of working on homework. If waking up is working on homework, then maybe. Let me see what you're working on. No class.
他看起来不像是在做家庭作业。如果醒着就是在做作业，那么也许是。让我看看你在做什么。没课。
When he does meet Kerry voters, it's a love fest. They sign the sheet pledging to vote for the senator, and they linger at the door with Andy, agreeing that Kerry won the debates, and that the war is a disaster, and Andy walks away thrilled, another one for his team. With the Bush voters, it's not a love fest, but everyone's cordial.
当他确实见到克里支持者时，那是一场爱之盛宴。他们签署pledge pledge支持参议员的表格，并与安迪在门口徘徊，同意克里赢得了辩论，战争是一场灾难，安迪走开时很激动，他的团队又多了一票。与布什支持者在一起，那不是一场爱之盛宴，但大家都客客气气的。
The biggest surprise, for me anyway, is our one undecided voter, a chatty guy named Joe, just out of college. Before today, I thought this was the whole purpose of canvassing, to persuade voters who are still on the fence, but when I actually see it happen, I realize why it's not the point at all, why Andy's script doesn't even bother with talking points.
对我来说，最大的惊喜是我们的一个未决定选民，一个叫乔的爱聊天的家伙，刚大学毕业。今天之前，我以为这就是拉票的全部目的，去说服那些还在犹豫的选民，但当我真正看到它发生时，我意识到为什么那根本不是重点，为什么安迪的脚本甚至不屑于谈论点。
While we're on the subject, I mean, you think back to like World War II, I mean, look at all those people in Germany, a lot of those people were-- not that it's happening here, but all that stuff can be going on, and we could be totally oblivious to it, because we're not informed, you know what I mean?
当我们谈到这个话题时，我的意思是，你回想第二次世界大战，看看德国的那些人，那些人中有很多——并不是说现在这里发生了这种情况，但所有那些事情都在发生，而我们可能对它完全不知情，因为我们没得到通知，你明白我的意思吗？
Andy talks to the guy, and talks to the guy, for almost 20 minutes. But Joe's such a ramble of random and conflicting opinions, I honestly believe no one could have swayed him.
安迪和那个家伙交谈，交谈，持续了将近20分钟。但乔的想法如此零散且相互冲突，我真诚地相信没人能动摇他。
Later, an organizer tells me that this is exactly why the thousands of canvassers going out in the next few days aren't really trying to persuade. They're trying to rally the voters already on their side. Simply making face-to-face contact with people can boost turnout on Election Day up to 12%. Down the block, in a white duplex, we meet this woman. She's 76 years old, tiny, with thin gray hair.
后来，一位组织者告诉我，这就是为什么接下来的几天里出去的数千名拉票员并不真正试图说服别人。他们是在集结已经站在他们这边的选民。仅仅与人面对面接触就能使选举日的投票率提高12%。在街对面，在一栋白色双拼房里，我们遇到了这位女士。她76岁，娇小，头发稀疏灰白。
Hi, is Mary home?
嗨，玛丽在家吗？
That's me.
那就是我。
Mary, hi, I'm Andrew Mills. I'm with MoveOn PAC. I wondered if you've decided who you're going to vote for in the election? Do you care to say?
玛丽，嗨，我是安德鲁·米尔斯。我是MoveOn PAC的。我想知道你决定在选举中投票给谁了吗？你想说吗？
ZZ Top.
ZZ Top乐队。
For president?
总统选谁？
Mmhmm.
嗯哼。
Mary stays inside and presses her nose to the screen door while we talk. She's not a ZZ Top fan, she says, but she's got nine kids, and some of them are.
玛丽待在里面，把鼻子压在纱门上和我们交谈。她说她不是ZZ Top的粉丝，但她有九个孩子，其中一些是。
He's not on the ballot in Ohio.
他在俄亥俄州的选票上不存在。
That's all right, it's a write-in.
没关系，这是填空投票。
You're going to write-in ZZ Top?
你要填空投票ZZ Top？
I don't think we have much choice.
我不认为我们有太多选择。
You don't know think we have much choice?
你不认为我们有太多选择？
No.
不。
You wouldn't rather see John Kerry in office, rather than President Bush?
你难道不想看到约翰·克里当政，而不是布什总统？
No.
不。
It doesn't really matter that much, which one of them, to you?
对你来说，他们中的哪一个真的没那么重要吗？
Like I said.
就像我说的那样。
OK. And you've sort of made up your mind about that?
好的。而且你已经为此做好了决定？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
At this point I can't help myself. I know I'm supposed to keep my mouth shut, but I don't understand her vote.
此时我无法控制自己。我知道我应该保持沉默，但我就是不理解她的选票。
Have you been happy with the way things are going in the country?
你对国家现在的进展满意吗？
No. I don't think we've got any business in Iraq, and I don't believe in abortion, so, you know. I mean, that's my two main problems.
不。我认为我们不应该插手伊拉克的事，我也不相信堕胎，所以，你知道。我的意思是，那是我的两个主要问题。
And so it's really split, because it's kind of like one guy--
所以这真的很纠结，因为这有点像是一个人——
Yeah, one's got us into war, and the other one's, you know, kill babies. I can't handle that.
是的，一个人让我们卷入战争，另一个人是，你知道，杀害婴儿。我受不了这个。
That's tough. That's tough to decide which one's more important.
这很难。这很难决定哪一个更重要。
ZZ Top sounds like more fun to me.
ZZ Top对我来说听起来更有趣。
I've gone out with other canvassers for this election, and each time I was struck by how inefficient it seemed, how few people you reach for all the hours you spend. Today, Andy knocks on 60 doors, and talks to a grand total of 17 people, 10 for Kerry, four for Bush, one undecided, one who won't say, one ZZ Top. In four hours, Andy didn't persuade anyone of anything.
在这次选举中，我和其他拉票员一起出去过，每次我都对这种效率低下感到震惊，你投入了那么多小时，却只能触及这么少的人。今天，安迪敲了60扇门，总共谈了17个人，10个支持克里，4个支持布什，1个未决定，1个不说，1个选ZZ Top。在四小时内，安迪没有说服任何人做任何事。
If anyone's been changed today, it seems to me, it's Andy. This morning, he was nervous, not just about knocking on doors, but about the election, what's going to happen if his guy doesn't win. But now he sounds relaxed, energized, even inspired. He's standing in the cluttered living room of a Kerry supporter named Marlene, who's sitting in a bathrobe, surrounded by prescription bottles, not sure if she's healthy enough to get to the polls.
如果今天有人被改变了，在我看来，那就是安迪。今天早上，他很紧张，不仅是因为敲门，而且是因为选举，如果不让他的人赢会发生什么。但现在他听起来很放松，精力充沛，甚至受到启发。他正站在一位克里支持者玛琳杂乱的客厅里，玛琳穿着浴袍坐着，被处方药瓶包围着，不确定自己的健康状况是否足够去投票。
Well, you know, I think it's going to come down, every vote in Ohio's going to count. We can do it. I mean, it may be just a few hundred votes.
嗯，你知道，我认为结果将会揭晓，俄亥俄州的每一张票都会计入。我们能做到。我的意思是，可能只有几百张票。
Yeah, all pull together.
是的，齐心协力。
You know, if we all turn out for him. It could be this neighborhood. It could be it's Columbus that's going to turn the election.
你知道，如果我们都出来投票支持他。可能是这个社区。可能是哥伦布市将扭转选举结果。
Put him over the top. I hope so.
让他胜出。我希望如此。
Yeah. So I'll tell you what, I may come by again just to make sure you got your absentee ballot, and if you didn't, we can arrange for someone to get you to the polls on Election Day if you need a lift. You know, because I want to make sure you get your vote counted.
是的。所以我告诉你，我可能会再过来一次，确保你拿到了缺席选票，如果你没有，如果需要搭车，我们可以安排人送你去投票站。你知道，因为我想确保你的投票被计入。
Andy's the first to admit he might not have much to show for the day. But after all the worrying about what's going to happen on Tuesday, it was a relief to get out and actually talk to people who'll be voting. The Kerry voters were reassuring. The Bush voters weren't demons. The abstract, mean-spirited, frightening battle for the future of everything that we've been seeing on TV turned into the simplest, least threatening thing in the world: two people standing on a porch, talking things out.
安迪是第一个承认他这一天可能没什么成果的人。但在对星期二会发生什么进行所有担忧之后，出去和将要投票的人进行交谈是一种解脱。克里的支持者令人安心。布什的支持者不是恶魔。我们在电视上看到的抽象、刻薄、可怕的未来斗争，变成了世界上最简单、最不具威胁性的事情：两个人站在门廊上，商量事情。
Lisa Pollak's a producer on our show.
丽莎·波拉克是我们节目的制片人。
The media's coming, the media's coming.
媒体来了，媒体来了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。